Pamela what should a screenwriter know
about writing about romantic love versus
fatal attraction and do the two ever
intersect good question the difference
between romantic love and a fatal
attraction I think is easily related to
the inner drives the centers of
motivation and that is when you are
driven by lust and then that obsession
that blind drive that's when you get
into the fatal attraction when you have
someone operating from the higher levels
of psychology and consciousness it's
more from the heart than it is from the
loins and in our book show me the love
we talk about transformative chivalric
love and the that's the kind of love
that makes you a better person because
you're striving to be worthy of the
beloved and the two people are
supporting each other and they only want
the best for each other so that kind of
love is romantic love and then the fatal
attraction kind of love is lust and sex
and obsession not that there's anything
wrong with that if it can make for great
drama but they are distinctly different
in the let's say in the motivation they
are distinctly different in the
motivation of the character who is
pursuing the love and in the fatal
attraction version they will do anything
and pay any price to get what they want
including kidnapping imprisoning killing
the rivals
blackmailing because they want what they
want and it's that physical lustful
connection which is very very strong you
know if it's what keeps all the species
going is that sexual drive and sexual
attraction so it's just natural part of
who we are the trick is not to get stuck
down there and so that then
transformative that chivalric love is
that which is coming from a higher
perspective and it's not so selfish it
is more inclusive and more giving it's
not you do what I want because I want
what I want
it's more like what shall we do how
shall we improve and it's very you know
worshipful and not necessarily chaste
but it's very respectful and caring but
it can also be really great you can also
have hot sex too so but the difference
is ultimately what you're after the
intention the intention absolutely the
intention is what makes the difference
and think of the film fatal attraction
where you've got Michael Douglas as the
pivot of that triangle and his wife and
Archer who wears white cotton panties
for goodness sake but she's she's
devoted to him she loves him that's the
the chivalric romantic love because they
build a life together and then Glenn
Close
who wears next to nothing black lacy
things is the fatal attraction lower
obsessive aspect of that sort of thing
the the fatal attraction and you really
see dramatically played out in that film
how that works and that diversity
between the two types of love
you